I read the story was not a biography,
if I remember correctly of the of the
captain.
I might be wrong about that,
but I've got the basic story,
right?
Well,
they had a ship wreck and the Antarctica
was then they were there for a whole
year in the Antarctic,
you know,
and none of them died.
Not One.
He didn't lose a single man,
not one.
He kept the morale high and then they
took this boat that was on the ship and
they crossed like 400 miles of the
roughest ocean,
the roughest,
frigid ocean in the world,
right.
You don't go in that ocean.
And then they went to an island and they
walked across the island across these
mountains that no one else has ever
climbed since,
and they went to the city on the other
side of the island and they got a boat
and they went and rescued their
compatriots and everyone survived.
It's like endurance is the name of the
book.
You read that book,
man.
You think,
wow,
people are really tough.
You know,
and if it's ridiculous.
So who knows how tough you are and maybe
you find out by going out to find out
how tough you are,
right?
So you take on a challenge,
one that you think you can master,
just that's just a bit beyond your grasp
and you master it and then your little
tougher and you think,
hey,
that worked out pretty well,
and so then you're more of a monster and
then you go out and you find another
challenge that's even bigger and you
think,
well maybe I can do that too,
and then all of a sudden you can and you
get a little bit bigger and God only
knows what the limit is of you and you
find out by pushing yourself against the
world.
And of course that's what Abraham is
doing.
And so see,
we're very pessimistic us more than
people were pessimistic about humanity.
That's for sure.
Dismal,
wretched planet destroying cancer on the
planet,
right?
As the club of Rome described us so
pleasantly back in the 19 sixties,
you know,
and,
and I don't know,
maybe we're ashamed of the Cold War.
Maybe we're ashamed of all the
destruction.
In the 20th century and the hydrogen
bomb and,
and the,
you know,
the continuing catastrophes of our
societies and were deeply ashamed of
that and ashamed of ourselves
personally,
but it's a hell of a thing to,
you know,
call us a cancer on the planet.
There's just no excuse for that because
what you do with cancer is eradicated.
And I don't think that that's a very
noble motive personally.
And I think it says a lot about the
people who would use such phraseology
that they would dare to conceptualize
humanity in that manner.
But you know,
it'd be nice if we could be optimistic
and I think began the problem with being
optimistic is that it's naive.
So then the question is,
is there an optimism that's not naive?
And I think there is and the optimism
that's not naive isn't just a
visualization of how strong people can
be.
So one of the things that I tell people,
I've told my students in my class in
maps of meaning,
here's a goal.
You want to be the person at the funeral
of your father that everyone can rely
on.
How would that be?
You want to be the person who's broken
and,
and useless and adding to the misery in
the corner.
And look,
I'm not making light of people's grief,
you know,
I understand grief,
but who do you want to be when there's a
crisis,
right?
Do you want to be the person that
everyone can turn to for strength?
It's like,
why the hell not?
Why not?
That is a goal.
That would be a good goal because then
if there's a crisis and there will be,
it won't be such a bloody crisis because
there'll be someone there that can deal
with it,
you know?
So when I went and talked to these
people at the funeral home,
I envisioned that I thought,
okay,
well this is something you have to
contend with.
If you're going to be alive and adult,
you have to contend with death and
suffering and you have to be ready for
it and you have to be there for the
person because that's all they're going
to have.
And so there's a goal man.
And in this time of nihilism,
you know what's,
what's the point of life?
People ask and they're taught that at
universities.
What's the point of life?
Everything's interpretation.
Humanities.
A cancer on the planet,
you know?
Well,
how about no?
How about not that?
How about the do something to us.